today i will talk about graph neural
networks in computational biology
and there has been a tremendous surge in
of interest in leveraging graph neural
networks and graph representation
learning
in particular for learning meaningful
representations of biology and
meaningful representations of data sets
and entities when
we encounter in biology and medicine and
so over the last few years we have seen
several prominent examples where dns
have been used successfully
to learn representations that have
enabled critical predictions in a
variety of downstream tasks
including predictions about discovering
novel interactions about
between proteins information about uh
treat uh success potentially successful
disease treatments
um opportunities about uh
novel regarding novel drugs and so on
and so
that has um that of course is
is very interesting and particularly um
a natural question to ask is
why do we see that graph neural networks
achieve such success in on biomedical
and biological data
and so to answer this question we need
to think a bit about um
biology and and observe that biology is
actually highly interconnected with
uh in in the sense that the way
drugs work when people take them is not
that they work
independently of each other but the way
drugs work is that they actually affect
certain number of molecules
uh in human cells that are typically
proteins
and those proteins interact with each
other and then
these effects are then propagated the
way they are propagated in
in human body and in human cells is
through those
underlying biological networks so we can
really see that biology is
interconnected at
various different scales from the scale
of genomic sequences where we see
interactions between parts of the genome
to the scale of interactions between
proteins and
molecules in within a cell to
interactions of external agents that are
included in the human body such as
drugs and therapeutics all the way to
the scale of populations or entire
ecosystems
where we have for example healthcare
systems and dependencies between
different
institutions different hospitals or
different kinds of symptoms within the
health within healthcare records
so the effects of many of biological
then interventions many of biological
entities are there really network
effects because of that it makes lots of
sense to study the biology through the
lens of networks and interactions
between biologically
relevant entities so to unpack this a
bit we can try to understand why our
networks in biology so powerful
and i look i will look i will take a
particular example
to to explain that so let's look for but
let's take a look at the human protein
interaction network this is a network
where nodes
um represent human proteins and two
proteins are connected by an edge
if the proteins physically interact
meaning that at some point in time the
two proteins are physically close in the
cell
and you might want to know well why
why are then proteins interacting with
each other
um if we look at a particular sub region
of a protein interaction network which
might be this particular subgraph on
uh on five human proteins where we see
uh five interactions
is there any significance between these
two protein mx
s1 and b92 so that they
in in the sense that what does it mean
and what are implications of them
interacting with each other
and to answer this question what we can
do is to overlay on that
um protein interaction network
information about
what are diseases that those proteins
are involved in
and if we do that for this particular
example we can see that
these three proteins that are
highlighted here in red
are all associated with the disease with
the same disease
meaning that when there are certain
alterations in those two proteins a
particular disease would
develop and so what is interesting
to to to explore and observe
is that if we overlay um information
about
involvement of proteins in various
diseases onto this
onto protein interaction network we can
see that
proteins associated with the same
disease tend to agglomerate or cluster
in certain regions
in certain neighborhoods of the network
and that has
over the last two decades yell to a very
powerful
paradigms in biology and medicine
because it's powerful as it allows us to
identify
new proteins that might be involved in
disease by simply exploring
the surrounding and network
neighborhoods of those proteins that
were already known to be associated with
the disease
that particular long-standing paradigm
is known
as local hypothesis in other words it
means that
proteins involved in the same disease
proteins that when mutated are
lead to the same disease they they have
an increasing tendency to interact with
each other
meaning that they would be connected in
our ppi network
so the implication of that local
hypothesis is that
uh mutations in interacting proteins
often lead to similar diseases
and now that we know that we can
effectively leverage that information
as spry information for for our for
our machine learning models while i
explain this particular local hypothesis
in the case of human protein interaction
networks and diseases
similar findings apply to a broad range
of different kinds of networks that we
can see in biology
going from protein to action networks to
networks where nodes
are patients related and connected based
on familial
or relationships or similarity of their
genomic profiles
to networks representing hierarchies of
cellular systems
networks representing disease pathways
gene interaction networks cell cell
similarity networks and many others
and so that notion of local hypothesis
where we see that
entities with similar properties or
tend to cluster and agglomerate in
certain network regions
um are is really one of the core
observations and motivation and guiding
principle
that can explain why graph neural
networks are so well suited for the
analysis
of biological networks and why they have
already led to several very
successful applications to biomedical
problems so
so that's all great and fantastic vision
that we can share it's a nice motivation
for right for why it makes sense to use
graph neural networks for biological
data
but biological networks also present
some fundamental
challenges that we can solve through
algorithmic innovation
so there are a number of challenges i
will just mention three here
um so the first challenge is that
biological networks tend to involve a
heterogeneous interactions that span
from the molecular level all the way to
the level of whole populations or
societies
and so typically the challenge is how to
computationally operationalize the data
what how to even construct then then
graphs that are then amenable
to to to machine learning the second
challenge is
that networks in biology contain data
that are
that come from a variety of different
resources
including experimental readouts curated
annotations and metadata
and we really need to consider all those
data
jointly because no single data type can
really capture all the
factors that are necessary to understand
a particular complex phenomenon such as
a disease it really
is um that we would we need to
uh jointly consider the data from
diverse resources to do so
and finally biological networks are by
definition
noisy and thereby definition are
incomplete because our understanding of
the nature
and biology is incomplete and they are
noisy because inherent
natural variations as well as
limitations of current
biotechnological platforms that generate
the data
which means that we need to operate with
the assumption
that our data will be missing it will
contain repeated measurements
even contradictory observations that can
plague the analysis
and methods need to be robust against
these issues
so the plan for today's lecture is the
following um i will
uh talk about three vignettes that will
highlight some of these challenges some
of the challenges
of for for work dealing with biological
networks as well as proposed solutions
and show examples of successful
applications of graph neural networks in
computational biology
so the parts that i will touch are the
first will be the question related to
modeling safety of drugs and um
safety of combinations of drugs second i
will talk about
predicting patient outcomes and disease
classification
and finally we will uh discuss um
um methods for identifying effective
disease treatments
and for identifying promising
therapeutic opportunities
for emerging diseases and along the way
i will also highlight some of
new technical work that was motivated by
the specific biomedical problems so
let's start with the first topic
which is that of uh modeling drug safety
and
modeling drug combinations to this work
is really motivated by the problem that
is known as polytherapy
sometimes also called polypharmacy it
refers to the situation where patients
take
multiple drugs at the same time to treat
complex or coexisting disease
this is a problem that is very common
actually
46 percent of people over 65 years take
more than
five drugs that are prescribed to them
by the doctor at the same time
it's not uncommon to encounter patients
that take more than 20 drugs to treat
heart diseases
depression cancer some other complex
disease
so the problem with that is that when a
patient takes
several drugs at the same time they're
at much higher risk for developing
adverse events
and there are estimates that around 50
percent of
15 of these population is affected by
those unwanted side effects
and that represents a huge burden both
for individuals as well as for the
entire healthcare system
in terms of rising healthcare costs
so when i said that individuals are at
higher risk of developing adverse
unadvantaged adverse events what did i
actually mean by that
so when patients take multiple drugs at
the same time
because we now know the drugs don't act
independently of each other
they might give rise to unexpected
interactions between drugs
so what does that mean let's look at
this hypothetical scenario
where we have a system with just two
drugs we have a blue pill and a red belt
so when a patient takes blue pill alone
there are no side effects observed and
the desired therapeutic effect if effect
is achieved and everything is
is well when a patient takes red pill
alone
no side effects are observed and
everything is okay however when a
patient takes blue and red pill together
then with certain probability
the patient would experience side
effects
um uh when taking that combination of
drug so that is surprising and
unexpected
because if the two drugs would act
completely independently of each other
then we would not expect to see
any significant side effects where the
two drugs are taken together
so our learning test for for for this
part of the talk
we will we is the following we want to
design a model
that will be able to predict how likely
a particular combination of drugs leads
to a particular side effect so that
is the uh the the test that we want to
solve
okay so a natural question to ask is now
that we know what is our question
is modeling drug combinations and modern
drug interactions really a challenging
problem
and the answer to that is yes it's a
very challenging problem
why is it so challenging first and
that's perhaps the core challenge
is that we can see combinatorial
explosion of possible combinations of
drugs
even if we take only a set of drugs that
are approved in the u.s and we consider
only combinations that consist of two
drugs
there are over 13 million possible
combinations of two drugs there are over
20 billion possible combinations of
three drugs
and many more higher order drug
interactions so the implication of that
is that this
is certainly infeasible and to test
safety of those combinations of drugs in
the lab
which effectively means that these drugs
are approved
by uh by fda and other regulatory
agencies
they get to the market and then patients
take them and then we see what happens
right so this is a huge opportunity for
computational models
to prioritize and upper identify and
flag those combinations of drugs that
might be unsafe before they are really
used
in real patients the second problem is
that
the unexpected drug interactions are by
definition
non-linear non-additive effects right an
interaction is defined as an effect that
is different
from what is an additive effect of
individual drugs which
presents its own set of challenges and
finally you might think of this
problem as a kind of big data problem
because we'll be working with
the set of all drugs in the u.s and all
adverse events associated with those
drugs and there will be millions of
those adverse event reports
but very quickly we get down to the
small data problem where actually for
any particular combination of drug there
is just a small numb subset of patients
that
take that combination of drugs and um
there might be actually no information
available about those combinations that
are not yet used in patients
so that's another challenge so to
tackle this particular challenge what i
will mention is an approach that is
called decagon that uses
that use graph neural networks to
predict
safety of combinations of drugs so
decagon was defined on a polypharmacy
knowledge graph
that had the following structure it's a
graph with
two kinds of entities drugs and proteins
so in this particular
case drugs are represented by green
triangles
an edge between two drugs has a
particular type so an edge of type r1
between two drugs
would indicate that a specific type of
interaction a specific adverse event
r sub one is observed when uh in
patients that take the two
um drugs uh together and that side
effects cannot be clearly attributed to
either drug alone
in that power of course in addition to
knowing
um include information about existing
interactions
between drugs we want to understand how
those drugs actually work in terms of
how what
part of the body and the effect and how
the they change activity of human cells
and so for that
the second node information the
knowledge graph connects drugs
to their protein targets and that
proteins are represented by uh orange
circles and then we know that proteins
uh
interact with each other which gives
rise to this underlying protein protein
interaction network
so given this um
multi-modal polypharmacy network the
project i would describe it is called
dicagon
has two components and so in the first
component in the encoder phase it will
take the multi-modal network it will
learn an embedding
for every drug and every protein node in
that
graph and then it will leverage those
embeddings to
predict labeled edges between drug nodes
that would correspond to predicted drug
interactions
or adverse events of combinations of
drugs so let's just
briefly take a look at that so the key
idea for generating
embeddings of drug and protein nodes in
that graph
was to um explore the local and look at
the local network neighborhoods for
every node in the graph
better and separate them by distinct
edge types
so that is achieved through two phases
where in the first phase for every node
cell node v
um we would determine a node's
computation graph
and there would be a separate
computation graph for each edge type
that
uh that that exists in the local
neighborhood of that node fee
and in the second phase uh the idea is
to take those computation graphs and
learn
what is the best way to propagate neural
messages along
edges of um of computation graphs
and trans and and then non-linearly
transform them
and so in this particular case we see
that for node v
node v has two uh two first order
neighbors that are of type r three
and three second order neighbors that
are of type are three
so that would be that would then define
a particular computation graph
for node v for an edge type r3 that
would uh
specify how information is propagated
along edges of that
edge type so this gives rise to
multi-relational graph encoder and in
2018 when the model was developed
the the architecture was relatively
simple and and i'm sure you're very
familiar
with these kind of architectures by this
firing the core so i'll very briefly
describe it
the idea here is that in the indica
note embeddings were initialized by node
features
which in the case of um poly pharmacy
problem
were features representing additional
information about
drugs and proteins such as drug
structure and protein memberships in
pathways and so on
so embedding for note v and then at
layer 0 was just initial
note feature of that note and then at
each layer um
of of the gnn the the embedding for node
to v was
was updated based on this particular
equation which what it
did it looked at all possible edge types
that um
that note v was involved in and for each
neighbor of note v in that particular
edge type for each neighbor u
um the method took the embedding of that
node u from the previous layer k minus
one
it combined that embedding um
by a trainable uh weight matrix that was
specific for the edge type that we are
currently looking at
and sort of that aggregated result was
that was then combined with the
embedding for note v
from the previous layer and non-linearly
transformed to get an updated embedding
for node view at layer k
um the weights for combining the uh
the embedding the it's uh its nodes
embedded from the previous layer as well
as the embeddings of the
neighbors at that point was defined by
normalization constant which was fixed
based on the node degrees today what
would certainly we would want to use our
attention mechanisms
but this particular equation was then
applied some large k
times where with large k would define
the number of layers and the final
embedding of the
the node is the embedding of the k
layers of that neighborhood propagation
aggregation schema so that is fairly
standard multi-relational graph encoder
by now
so the the result of multi uh of that
graphing code there were embeddings for
drug
and protein nodes and so once in
embeddings for those nodes were obtained
um then the edges were
labeled edges between drug nodes were
predicted and for that the input was
uh was consists of embeddings of two
nodes c and x
those would be two particular drugs and
so embeddings of those
two and s were combined by um
a particular type of thinser
factorization
um that um was a style of dd contains or
that took embeddings for a pair of drunk
notes
um and combined and multiplied them
by uh two diagonal matrices that were
relation specific and essentially
encoded in contribution of specific
embedding dimensions towards a
particular
side effect and then a matrix r
which was a small non-fully non-zero
matrix
that allowed the model to capture any
kind of
dependencies between any pair of
dimensions in the learned embedding
and so the output was then of of this
decoder were then predicted edges
of there for every pair for every
particular side effect
um the model would return the
probability that the
the given pair of drugs would interact
through that particular side effect
okay so in order to then apply this
model to the polypharmacy knowledge
graph
the first thing to do is to construct
the actual polypharmacy knowledge graph
so the data
that was used to do so was captured
molecular drug and patient data across
all drugs prescribed in the u.s
and for that a unique data set was built
that consisted of
over 4 million drug drug edges those are
currently known interactions between
pairs and drugs that was
that were retrieved from the fda
information on
drug protein edges and information on
protein protein edges as well as site
features on nodes
so that gave rise exactly to this
multi-model knowledge graph that
we have seen earlier which had over um
around five million edges altogether
and it was highly multi-relational as
there were
1000 different edge types in that uh
graph
once the model was the data set was
constructed um
and um dicker one was fully specified
then
um the dicargon uh model was trained on
the polypharmacy
knowledge graph in an effort to answer
questions of the following form so the
users could then
post a query uh for example whether a
form of
statin and ciprofloxacin which are too
drunk
when taken together would they lead to
breakdown of muscle tissue
that affection effectively meant that in
the back end the model was asked with
predicting the probability
that uh these two drugs um are
connected in the graph by an edge of
type r2 if r2 would indicate breakdown
of muscle tissue
so once the model was trained it was
compared against
several baselines baseline algorithms at
that point in time
so these the results are shown in this
slide where in the on the y-axis we see
performance higher performance higher
values indicate better performance as
measured by a rock and average precision
at the top 50
and uh the performance of the cargo
model is shown in red
performance of other bass lines um
is shown in um brown blue and green
color so the particular base lines that
were considered here
was a simple rescul tensor factorization
which can be thought of as decagon
that does not use the deep graph encoder
and so that
has that test has shown that it's really
important
to use graph convolutions to learn
powerful embeddings
so then dicargon was compared to a
multi-relational factorization which
is uh which um um and it's
the the relative improvement of decagon
over that factorization showed that
it's it's really important to be able to
model side effects jointly because there
are some correlations between side
effects
and and finally then uh dickerwood was
compared to a shallow network embedding
model
embedding model which was a nautovic
style model
um and the improvement there showed that
um then
the new the message passing network is
is much better
in terms of performance in this
particular application uh than
some of the random walk based uh
embeddings at that time
so another test that was done was to um
do um apply dicargon in a temporal
fashion meaning the decline was trained
on all the data generated prior to 2012
and then uh the model was frozen and it
was asked to make predictions
um that the model is most confident
about
and we then test that well how many of
those predictions have been confirmed
after 2012.
so what is shown in this particular
slide is our top 10 predictions made by
the model
and so recall that each prediction comes
in the form of a pair of drugs and
side effects associated with that pair
of drugs and so for five out of those
top 10 predictions direct evidence was
found
published after 2012 showing
that showing examples of real patients
who were on a particular combination of
drugs and have experienced the kind of
side effect that the
one has actually predicted will happen
so for example for drug uh prediction
number eight
the there there are several reports of
of patients
who took a statin and unload dipping
together and experience muscle
inflammation and those reports were made
after 2012
and which is which provides evidence for
for for
prediction made by the model some of the
novel predictions in this space are
novel hypotheses that can
that warrant further analysis and and
downstream investigations
in several collaborations with domain
experts who are in work in this disease
and drug areas
that has actually been done more recent
follow-up
um on the dikagon study is concerned
with
modeling adverse events at the level of
patient groups
in an effort to make predictions about
what are adverse events
that might be associated with certain
group
of individuals though where those groups
can be defined by
age by gender or by individuals that
have certain kinds of
certain diseases and so um
what i'm mentioning this because um the
data is already um
pre-processed and provided to this study
um and and so those who are interested
in potentially
leveraging gnns for doing more
personalized level adverse event
prediction this is certainly something
that can that is possible now to do with
this data set that contains over 10
million
adverse event reports okay so this
concludes my
my first um vignette our first topic a
large topic for today
and the next topic will will change the
gears
and we will move away from predicting
safety of drugs
instead now we will um we will think
about
diagnosing patients which is important
crucial question
that uh first need to be answered before
any drugs can be actually or treatments
can be actually
identified and recommended to the
patient
so let me start with the motivation of
disease diagnosis
uh so the core information for
a disease for diagnosing a disease
broadly speaking
is the information about phenotypes that
are seen and observed in a particular
patient so phenotypes can be defined
as some observable characteristics
that uh that um can be seen are
uh in a patient and they result from
various interactions between the
genotype
and the genomic information between the
patient as well as
environment in the patient sleeps so
physicians typically utilize
uh various standardized vocabularies of
phenotypes to describe human diseases
for example a very prominent
standardized
vocabulary phenotype is known as human
phenotype
ontology and that codifies
a very a variety of different phenotypes
and how they map to human diseases
so by mod by by modeling diseases then
as collections of phenotypes or or that
represent the disease we could then
diagnose patients based on what are the
phenotypes that they have based on what
are the symptoms that those patients
would have
so in machine learning we can define the
diagnosis task
then in the following manner we will
start with a graph
so consider for in this particular
example a graph that is built from the
standardized vocabulary phenotypes that
would be a graph where nodes
are phenotypes that those might be
visible symptoms as well as various
phenotypes at the molecular or genomic
level
and edges between those phenotypic nodes
would indicate different kinds of
relationships between phenotypes
we can in that setting the disease would
then be represented as a set of nodes or
as a subgraph
in that phenotypic network so the
learning task
would then be the diagnosis test is then
concerned with
where predicting the the label
or predicting the disease that is most
consistent with a particular subgraph
s that describes the patient so you can
think of now
that patients are these different
subgraphs of phenotypes that patients
have
and the goal is to predict labels which
in this particular case are colors of
these subgraphs
and those labels are the diseases that
uh
that are candidate diseases patients
might have
okay so given this formulation uh
let's uh let's discuss the algorithm for
this problem a bit and then we will
return back to the data in the diagnosis
task
so in the context of graph neural
network a problem formulation is the
following
the goal here will be actually to learn
embeddings for sub graphs
such that adult uh those embeddings for
that for subgraphs that are learned we
capture well uh the topology of
interactions between nodes as well as
where they are where they exist
in the context of um the underlying
graph so that
means that um that the input um
which then consists of the some
underlying graph g and a large number
of sub graphs that have labels and the
goal is to learn
subgraph embedding such that two
subgraphs as a pi and sub j
that have similar subgraph topology and
i will define next what that means
they should be embedded close together
in the embedding space so represented
by nearby points in the embedding space
that we wanted to learn
so why are subgraphs challenging so why
can we for example just take our
favorite
note level and better and by now i'm
sure you have heard of
many notes level and better in the
course and essentially just learn not
embeddings and and take an
average of those note embeddings or
somehow um aggregate those not
embeddings to arrive at the subrafa
betting
so there are several reasons why we we
might lose a lot
of information if you do so so one of
them is that um the subgraphs that we
would encounter in the diagnosis task
are subgraphs of varying sizes and
then the question is really how to
represent those subgraphs effectively
that are not
simple k-hawk neighborhoods around a
single center node second subgraphs
would have rich connectivity structures
both internally
as well as externally through
interactions with the rest of the graph
so how can we inject that information
into our gns
and finally subgraphs that are given by
uh sets of phenotypes for patients
can be localized in the sense that they
would reside in a single region in
single large neighborhood of the graph
such as this hypothetical example where
the subgraph is indicated by this red
blob that is called to the center
of core of the graph or subgraphs may be
distributed across
many multiple local neighborhoods and so
um then a simple averaging of node
embeddings might not be an effective
strategy
so to tackle this problem uh what was
developed was a subgraph neural network
model
and so the problem that the subgraph
neural network is solving
is the following it assumes that given
our some
set of subgraphs s this set has an uh
n subgraphs s 1 s 2 up to s n sub g n
specifies then a neural message passing
architecture
that will generate um the sub
s-dimensional
subgraph representation for every
subgraph in that set
and it will use those representations to
learn a sub-graph level classifier
so function that will then map those
subgraphs to
some number of discrete labels and the
way it will do so
is by really taking into account
different kinds of subgraph topology in
particular
the parts of subway topology that we are
interested in is related to capturing
the connectivity within the
immediate local neighborhood of each
subgraph
both the internal in within a subgraph
as well as at the border of the subgraph
and
the graph g the information about the
structure of the subgraph in the sense
of are there certain motifs that are
over or underrepresented in a subgraph
as well as where is that subgraph
located
relative to the graph g in in in which
it exists so a
quick note on problem formulation that i
want to give here
is that sub g n puts forward a
definition of
subgraph prediction learning task this
is different
from other canonical tasks on graphs
that are primarily concerned with
a note level predictions and
representations where the goal is to
predict properties
of an individual note in the graph or
link prediction which is concerned with
predicting properties
of a pair of nodes or graph level
prediction which is concerned with
predicting properties of entire graphs
so sub g n is concerned
with predicting properties of subgraphs
of non-trivial size meaning not
subgraphs or sizes
which would correspond to an edge the
way this is done
is that sub-genen consists of two parts
so the first important part
is a message passing scheme that is
hierarchical in nature
in it specifies the way neural messages
are propagated from anchor patches
which are helper graphs sampled from g
to subgraphs s that we want to embed
and how those messages are then embed um
aggregated to arise at the final subrag
embedding
and in part three in part two that
routing of messages is really done to
three distinct channels where each
channel corresponds to a
distinct aspect of subgraph topology
position neighborhood and structure that
we want to capture
uh very brief briefly let me describe
these two parts so the subraf message
passing
uh scheme is has the following structure
um
there are neural messages
specified those messages are specific
for each of the three properties
so they're denoted m sub x and those
messages are propagated from
anchor patches to sub-graph components
anchor patches are just helper
sub-graphs that are sampled randomly
from the underlying gravity and there
are three different kinds of patches
depending
to capture for uh to capture position
neighborhood and structure
so um then the the the mesh
passing is then formulated as the
message from
this anchor patch a to subgraph s
is uh is sent and it's scored based on
its way its contribution is weighted
by a similarity function between a
subgraph component and an anchor patch
that represents a weight of how much
an embedding of the anchor patch will
contribute to embedding of the subgraph
so this is visually shown here in the
right part of the slide
where the the sub graph that that is
part of the data that we want to embed
is sub one this subgraph actually has
two disconnected components
it one is here on on the left part and
the right part of the
uh the right uh stream of the graph
and in the message passing phase those
helper patches
um anchor patches which are in gray send
their messages to the subgraph component
those set of messages that are received
at the subgraph component are aggregated
and then the the aggregated message of
the subgraph component is combined with
its previous
component with its previous embedding
to get a property specific
representation of
uh subgraph component so h sub x c
is then an embedding for um subgraph
component c
so it would be just for this fir one
component of the subgraph sub one
that captures the aspect x
which can be positioned neighborhood or
structure
so the way this message passing is done
is done in three separate channels
and each channel it describes um a
particular
is designed to capture one aspect of
topology position neighborhood and
structure
each channel x has three key elements
those elements are similarity function
that weighs messages exchanged between
anchor patches and subgraph components
then a set an anchor patch sampling
function that specifies how
these helper patches need to be
sampled from the underlying graph in
order to capture
neighborhood or c and capture diverse
neighborhoods and diverse structure and
diverse positions
and finally how to encode those anchor
patches and these functions can be
learned or predefined
and so the recap of that is that we can
think of this problem
as um as the problem of learning
subgraph representations
as um as a message passing network that
has three distinct channels
and those channels output channel
specific
embeddings that are then aggregated to
produce a final
subgraph representation z sub s for
subgraph s
so let's now return to our problem of
disease diagnosis
and the first thing we will do we will
uh as we will
we will test whether that method works
on
some simulated synthetic data sets to
really see whether the method can truly
capture
the distinct aspects of subgraph
topology and the setup for that was the
following
in each case each dataset started with
the base graph
and base graph was then sprinkled
with a large number of subgraphs there
were two strategies to define
subgraphs either to one strategy was uh
was the planting strategy where a
subgraph was generated and it was
planted
on top of the base graph or it would be
essentially
essentially just joined in the form of
uh in similar way as it would be stapled
together with the base graph
in this particular subgraph in this
particular synthetic
data sets each sub for each subgraph a
label was defined
and so labels were defined based on
certain network structural properties
of those subgraphs so one particular
synthetic data set was called density
where that was a data set where um that
consists of the underlying base graph
with and then a large number of
subgraphs the labels
of those subgraphs were beamed values of
density network density metric
and similar data sets were constructed
for that based on
cut ratio metric coordinates and
component why would you want to do that
the idea was to do that to test whether
really the most informative channels for
certain types of labels
are those channels that really truly
determine the label so this is really a
controlled environment of testing
performance of the model
and so those results show that sub gnn
is
is an effective strategy for learning
subgraph embeddings that outperforms
various simple attack measures that one
could think of
for example taking a simple average of
note embeddings uh and and obtain
subgraph embeddings in this way
or introduce a meta artificial node and
then embed those meta nodes that could
serve as proxies for subgraph embeddings
or even doing graph level embeddings
finally this these results also show
that the sub gen and can capture well
different aspects of subgraph topology
that was can be studied
by looking what which of the three
channels
neighborhood position or structure would
be most informative for predicting
certain kinds of labels so for the case
of density
um the label would primarily be
determined by
uh the neighborhood of the subgraphs so
what was then tested is whether the
neighborhood channel is most informative
for predicting
the density labels and indeed that was
the case
okay so now that we we know that sub g n
works well let's return to our real
world data set
so there were four real world data sets
that were designed for the problem of
uh clinical diagnostic tasks
so each of the four data sets consists
of a base graph and subgraphs with
associated labels
so the two uh uh the the two data sets
that i want to bring your attention to
are called hbo meetup and hpo neural
so these are the data sets where the
base graph is the
graph of um from the human phenotype
ontology so this is a graph for nodes
are human phenotypes edges
are hierarchical relationships between
phenotypes and symptoms
that we see in human populations and
then labels are defined by
certain uh by uh subgraphs are defined
by subgraphs of metabolic um uh diseases
and metabolic disorders
that uh affect humans and in the hpo
neural
data set then subgraphs represent
various neurodegenerative diseases so
the goal of those two
those these two particular data sets is
to
define is to predict subgraph labels
that
correspond to various metabolic or
neurological diseases
that are consistent with the underlying
phenotypes so this simulates the
environment
of diagnosing patients that might have
metabolic or neurological disorders
so let's see performance of sub g n
across
those um four data sets with a
particular focus on
the human phenotype ontology neura and
metabolic data set
and so what we can see is that the
performance of
sub g n when even uh implemented with uh
um
when compared to um baseline models
is substantially better and sub g n
outperforms
the those uh baseline models considered
here
by up to 127 25 which is a really
incredible improvement in performance
which clearly motivates the
use of subgraphs rather than simply
considering node level or graph level
aggregation
okay so this concludes the second part
of
this talk which was concerned with
using the power of subgraph embeddings
and gns for
disease diagnosis tasks and in the first
in the third part of the talk
i will uh focus on
important endpoint for drug development
which is that of drug efficacy
so in the first part we talked about
drug safety but uh and drugs
and safety is one of two cornered
endpoints
that we care about in the drug
development process in addition to drug
safety the second important end point
is efficacy where the question is to
understand
whether a certain molecule that might be
candidate drug
will really have positive therapeutic
effect in patients
so let's uh start with this third part
of the talk the motivating fact
the the motivating uh problem for this
uh task was
the question of how to find cures for
emerging diseases
this particular work was motivating by
the onset of the kovit pandemic last
year
where um it was became clear that
um at the at the beginning of the
pandemic
their the need was for rapid
deployment and identification of drugs
that might have positive therapeutic
effect in
um in 19 patients but simply traditional
approaches of iterative development
experimental testing and clinical
validation and approval of new drugs
were not feasible
because they on average take over a
decade to bring and
design a new drug from scratch and bring
it to market and that was simply not
feasible
so a more realistic strategy relied on
repurposing of drugs
requiring us to essentially identify
what are drugs that are clinically
approved
that might have therapeutic effect in
copic 198 patients
and so the particular study that i will
be mentioning
is um is the is the one that was
conducted
that started at the beginning of march
last year
and the most parts of it were done
between march
and last summer and it really
demonstrates
an opportunity of how in this particular
case graph neural networks
were able to compress years of work into
actually weeks in some cases actually
days of work
by through very close collaboration
between machine learning models
predictions that provided by those
models and end users which in this case
were virologists and experimental
biologists who took predictions and
experimentally
screened them in the lab okay so
that's that that is our our goal for for
this part of the talk let's let's now
try to
uh uh unpack and define the problem of
drug repurposing first
and then describe our technical approach
for for for this
problem so as i mentioned the discovery
of a new
development of new drug from scratch is
a very lengthy resource intensive
process
it on average takes more than a decade
and it costs one to two billion dollars
to design
a new drug from scratch and so faced
with the skyrocketing costs for
developing new drugs
researchers are looking at ways to
repurpose older ones
to essentially take drugs that are
already on the market and ask
are there any other kind of diseases
that those drugs might be effective
and that is very appealing strategy
because it would be much shorter and
potentially much more effective
most famous example of a drug that was
repurposed on the market
is is is viagra that was initially
designed for treating cardiovascular
diseases
but then during clinical trials it
turned out that there might be other
indications that it would be useful for
and so while in the past those
repurposing strategies were primarily
coincidental findings there is now
concerted effort of
can we systematically go through drugs
that are clinically approved and are on
the market and identify possible
therapeutic opportunities
so the court describes now the core this
problem is the following question
which we can think of it as a link
prediction problem in a bar pie touch
graph
where on the left we have a set of drugs
those might be all approved drugs plus
investigational experimental drugs
um some drugs that failed in clinical
trials but otherwise are not
hugely unsafe for patients and on the
right we would have
tens of thousands of diseases which are
codified diseases
that could be described for example
through a set of phenotypes that we were
discussing in the second part of the
talk so edges connecting drugs to
diseases here would indicate
non-treatment relationships the problem
that we have here our goal is to have a
model
that will predict what diseases a new
molecule or an existing drug
might treat so is this a challenging
problem
why is finding treatments for a new
disease in particular such a challenging
problem
so when we're cons when we are concerned
with the question of
finding treatment for a new emerging
disease that
means that we want to identify drugs
that might treat the disease
but there are no currently known drugs
for that disease
so and kovit was a very very prominent
example of that
early last year and so conceptually
technically that means that that's not
surprising because we know
in machine learning the generalizing to
new phenomena is typically hard
prevailing graph neural network methods
still assume and require
abundant label information in order to
be really trained effectively and
achieve high accuracy
however i would argue that one of the
definitive factors of
a frontier of biology and medicine are
problems
where labeled examples are incredibly
scarce
and this includes emerging diseases such
as scopic 19
rare diseases hard to diagnose patients
modeling novel toxin development
and many many other problems so what
prevailing methods assume is that we
start with graphs that are already
richly labeled
that assumption is heavily violated in
most exciting problems where in reality
what happens in the world that we only
have a handful of labels
uh for a particular class if any at all
so to for for the for the problem of
drug repurposing
that uh and the method and the gene and
methodology that i will describe
it really relies on view shot learning
and meta learning so i have two slides
now
with just a very brief high level
overview of that uh of what metal
learning is and i assume that many have
already heard about this in
other courses so um
meta learning is very effective strategy
for for learning in the cases where
there are a very few small number of
labeled examples available for
for for tasks and so typically the idea
of
meta learning strategies is the
following we assume that we have a meet
we train a meta learning model over a
variety of learning tasks
and that model is optimized for to
achieve the best performance on a
distribution of tasks including
potentially unseen tasks
the way to think of metal learning is
that think of
each learning task being defined and
associated with a small data set
d that contains both data instances
feature vectors and some true labels
and so meta learning is then concerned
with
it finding the optimal parameters
data star for the model that would
minimize the loss function across those
a large number of data sets each
describing a different task
so if those models can be find success
if those parameters dita star can define
successfully
that indicates that the model was able
to really successfully generalized from
one task
to the other from one data set to the
other and so if can
if it can do that effectively through
the process known as meta training then
we can hope
that also in the case of at test time it
will be able to very quickly very
effectively
adapt to a new task in our case that
will be a new disease called
19. so this looks very similar to just
normal regular machine learning test but
you can think of essentially
one data sample is not a single node
it's not a single
edge in the graph but essentially a data
sample is
is a small data set which in our case
would be a small part
of the graph on which the model is
trained
so as a second slide of the background
of metal learning is
is about few short learning which is
just a specific instantiation
of meta learning in the field of
supervised learning and i'm mentioning
that just because i want to introduce
another
one notation and that notation is
uh describes the difficulty of a few a
few short learning tasks
where we will say that we are interested
in solving
a k shot and class classification
problem
that which meaning that we want to solve
a task for
that in a problem for which we only have
k labeled examples for each of n classes
so what is shown in here in this slide
is an example of a two-shot three-way
image classification where we would
have um where each task would consist of
classifying image class images into
three classes
that's why it's three-way image
classification and for each class we
have two examples
and so the process here would be the
during training phase
we def we sample and define a large
number of training
tasks each of them is an instance of
two-shot three-way image classification
and so if the model can be successfully
primed to to
solve this uh to solve
this task during meta training phase
then in during meta testing time
then uh the model would would quickly
adapt
to completely new set of classes
for which only a handful of labels are
given as well the goal that we will have
here now that we have this background on
future learning and meta learning is how
to
how to make predictions um on a new
graph or a new label set
so essentially we want to use viewshot
learning not on for image classification
we want
but we want to use use it for graphs
okay um so the problem formulation
um is of this problem is the following
uh
we are interested in designing a meet a
learner uh that meta learner will be
concerned with
um will need to be able to classify an
unseen label set so that could be a blue
label set
by observing some other label sets in
the same graph
so during um training uh the model will
be learned only on yellow
labels and we would expect that the
model would be would be able to
generalize to
blue labels that are defined within the
same graph um
during uh test time and so the method
that does that
is called um is called gmata the
overview of gmeta
if i present it in similar way as i have
done for a few short learning
just a few slides ago it's very similar
to the general feedback learning setting
but now we are not concerned with um
solving image classification tests but
we are concerned with solving
graph um um learning problems
um in for the case of this explanation
those would be node classification
problems
where during training time we would
define a large number of
tasks each um from a different from a
particular label set and at
test time the new task will be presented
on label set 3 that would not be seen
that was not present during training
time
so the key idea that gmata uses to solve
this uh to solve the fuselage learning
problem on graphs
is that it will specify an um
a signature function for each learning
task that signature function will be
defined based on the structure of
subgraphs that encompass uh labeled
examples in each task
and then those subgraph signature
functions will essentially learn
that we'll learn how to map the
structure of sampled subgraphs
representing
task and how and effectively
uh serve us initialization for a gnn and
so this strategy can be really
effectively the strategy of extracting
subgraphs that enclose
labeled examples and then applying gene
into each subgraph individually
is effective strategy for doing for
doing few shot learning
a natural question to ask now is just
conceptually which is an interesting
question
what is the value of these local
subgraphs that we are using now
to transfer knowledge from one disk to
the other and the reasoning for why
subgraphs
are useful here is the following you can
think of
there are two fundamental core sources
of information that gnns are using
one is based that on label propagation
where we can think of
nodes that have the same label they tend
to be nearby in the graphs we have seen
at the beginning of the lecture today
that proteins that tend to interact
they are also tend to lead be
affiliated with similar phenotypes and
lead to similar diseases
the other core source of gene and power
is structural similarity
where nodes that have the same label
they might not be nearby in the graph
but they
might have similar network shapes in
their local neighborhoods
okay so now that we know that we know
that
in the case of few short learning where
labels are really scarce that we then we
cannot rely much on label propagation
it's simply not sufficient
it's it when only a handful of nodes are
labeled it's very challenging to
effectively propagate labels to the
entire graph
so instead we can much better leverage
structural information
and structural equivalence which is
exactly what these local subgraphs
uh capture as a mechanism for
transferring knowledge across tasks
and it is actually possible to show
theoretically
that local subgraphs that are defined
around
labeled examples capture much of
relevant information for prediction
and beyond theoretical findings
it has been well demonstrated
by many studies in the context of
biological networks
that typically most useful information
for
that describes a particular task um in
the context of biological networks exist
in some two three hop neighborhoods
around target nodes so the use of
local subgraphs is then highly motivated
okay so
let's return now finally uh to our covet
19 repurposing problem
and so i i will start with description
of the data set
on which this the the the this transfer
this diffusion learning strategy that i
described was applied
so the repurposing data set had has
three
major components the first was
information on
how to even represent kovic knight okay
how can we represent it
in the form of a graph or some structure
that that is
machine readable that we can actually
compute over
and so to do that we relied on the study
that uh was published in um last year in
um in nature by gordon natal and
colleagues from ucsf
and they what they have done but they
have expressed
26 out of 29 proteins
in sars coffee virus and they have
checked
what are human proteins that those viral
proteins attack
and so in doing so they identified 332
human proteins to reach the of two
virus binds and so that can be used as
essentially computational computable
representation of coffee 19.
kovite 19 can be then represented by
that set or
subgraph or structure of 332
human proteins that are directly
attacked by the virus so these are known
as
viral human protein protein interactions
because there are actually interactions
between the virus
and humans the second important
information was
that on what are other proteins that
those
attacked proteins interact with
so that is the human interactive network
or the human protein protein direction
network
and the third piece of information was
the information about um existing drugs
on the market
so for each and every existing drug we
put information on its known
targets on proteins that those drugs
bind to and that gave
rise to those drug modules which would
be a set of proteins for each drug that
are that are targeted
when the patient takes the drug
so called 19 ultimately was represented
as a network neighborhood of human ppi
network
targeted by sarskoft virus and the
flu shot learning strategy was then
applied
to learn the embedding four kovi
kovic 19 that was the new task which
is that we wanted to rank
drugs for based on how promising they
might be for coffee knighting
the way the model was optimized it was
optimized based
on known drug disease implications
for other drugs and other diseases
that are much better understood than
covet 19.
so that process yelled an embedding
space for
approved drugs and diseases uh one point
in that embedding space was the point
that represented kovic 19.
so an effective way to identify or
repurposing opportunities for call with
19 was to look at
what are other um water drugs
that are embedded close to the kovic 19
this
embedding and then prioritize
drugs based on that closeness between
uh kovic 19 embedding and the drug
embeddings
and that that gives rise to a ranked
list of drugs
where those at the top represent most
promising algorithm most promising
opportunities for repurposing in the
context of calling 19.
the first test to do when you have such
a model
is to try to get a some understanding
into how
accurate those predictions are so what
this plot is showing
it is an a rock uh plot um that
um shows on the x-axis false positive
rate on the y-axis true positive rate
of a prediction problem which was
defined as
a question of can can these models
effectively identify those drugs that
were
in april 2020 investigated on clinical
trials for kobit 19.
and so a number of baseline methods were
tested for this
question uh the three g and n based
methods the four gen and based methods
are called
a1 are denoted a1 up to a4 and they
showed substantial improvement
in performance relative to some other
networks
medicine based uh strategies based on
diffusions
random mods network proximity and others
that are more commonly deployed in the
field of drug repurposing
that finding it by itself however while
promising it's not particularly exciting
because the fact that
a drug is investigated in clinical trial
for covet 19 does not really mean that
it's successful
and so a real test of the accuracy of
and ability of the predictions being
useful is to experimentally validate
predictions
so for that um biologists and
virologists from the national emerging
infectious disease laboratories so this
is a national laboratory that can work
with live
viruses and it looks like like this so
it looks like very
kind of almost like some kind of
environment
in the space where nobody can enter
accept those with uh
very particular access and they are able
to work with
life viruses there so the virologists
there took
the top predictions made by the model
and then test screen those predictions
for their efficacy um
in first african monkey cells which are
zero e6 cells a very prominent cell line
for kovic 19 tests
and later in mouse in human cells
so the result of that was that uh 77
drugs that were predicted showed strong
or weak effect
and they were active over a broad range
of concentrations
importantly those predictions that were
obtained
by gnn and actually an assemble of
metals including some of the other
network medicine methods
gave an order of magnitude higher heat
rate
among top predictions than prior work
so prior work would be just brute force
tests of all drugs
in a in a in in in the lab
and if that is not done in a brute force
manner but it's rather informed by
prioritized list of drugs
produced by by by ml models
then um an order of magnitude uh
better heat rate is something that we
could expect
since we are in the machi in a course
which is concerned about networks there
is an interesting finding that i want to
mention here
um and so a natural question to ask is
great
so this analysis identified 77 drugs
what is there something common to those
drugs that inhibited viral growth
and so the answer to that question is
yes so 76 out of 77
drugs that were predicted and and
experimentally showed that they
successfully reduced viral infection
were those kind of drugs that do not
directly bind to
those human proteins that the virus
directly attacks
instead those drugs rely on
network-based action
those drugs such as d3 here would
target some human proteins that are not
directly attacked by the virus and those
human proteins in turn would interact
with some other proteins who in turn
finally would be exactly those proteins
that the virus attacks
why am i mentioning that is
because these kind of drugs which we now
call network drugs
are could not be identified by
traditional
strategies for drug purposing which in
computational biology
and computational pharmacology are based
on docking
okay so since i'm already running over
time i will
wrap up here so to summarize the lecture
today we talked about interesting
applications of graph neural networks
in computational biology and we touched
two top three topics
we talked about using gnns for modeling
us
in drug combinations and identifying
adverse events and
concerns regarding safety of drugs we
then talked about opportunities for
that gnns present for uh defining
diagnostic tasks and classifying
diseases and finally we talk about
a ways of for using gnns to identify
um promising therapeutic opportunities
with a particular
angle which was that of opportunities
for never before seen emerging diseases
so i um this concludes my last lecture
here and very happy to take
questions thank you uh thank you very
much marinka
uh this was awesome um would you wanna
uh comment
a bit more about what do you think are a
big challenges in
biomedicine that are ready to be
attacked by machine learning ai methods
well that's a very uh that's a very
broad
question so the way i would think of
biomedicine is um in the following way
so
we can broadly think about certain core
problems so one core problem is
um related to diagnosing patients
before any kind of treatment can be
identified
or any kind of drug can be recommended
we first need to know what
are uh what is the disease that the
patient has
so a core challenging problem that is
that is ready to be tackled from the ml
standpoint here
is in particularly
we need methods for rapid diagnosis of
patients
in particular those patients that have
that are hard to diagnose and have many
rare novel diseases
you might say well that might not be
lots of patients but it turns out that
20 percent of all patients in the u.s
have this kind of diseases and on
average a patient patients we trade
these
rare diseases need to visit seven
specialists before they are correctly
diagnosed
that's again a huge problem for
healthcare systems for individuals et
cetera et cetera
so now the data sets are available to
expedite the diagnosis tasks
considerably so i think that's one
exciting problem and direction to pursue
sorry just to ask a follow-up so do you
think of this as a
active learning type problem where you
also recommend what other tests
to take so that you can diagnose the
disease
um probably not because uh
the problem is that if you think of if
you look at those patients
they already went through many many
tests they more or less they took lots
of different tests and we don't know
what
what else to do so it's not that much a
question of identifying what
lab tests should they conduct but the
problem is that
you we can ask ourselves why we cannot
diagnose patients easily
the problem is that they are they're
conflicting in some way
meaning that a patient would come and
put present
presents with phenotypes and symptoms
that don't match with any known disease
classification
right so the way patient comes to the
physician the physician has a huge book
they they open and they say okay this is
a these are the symptoms that i would
expect for disease a
and they compare that with patient
symptoms there's no match okay so no
this is a
let's go to disease b let's go to dcc
and the problem that it's hard to
diagnose those patients is that
they somehow have a mixture of symptoms
that
don't align well with any of the disease
so it's it's really more about
essentially diagnosing them and the
question is what is a good diagnosis
probably it's not just saying a patient
has
disease a but it has this this set of
diseases which or or can we learn some
kind of distribution over
known diseases that capture that patient
well and so
it's just the first task of identifying
what's what's
wrong with the hindi or with the
individual right the immediate next
question is can one identify successful
treatments
and so here all the questions related to
drug discovery development
apply in the sense of can we repurpose
existing drugs can we
identify combinations of drugs that
might work for a patient
can we do that in a more personalized
way and it's possible now
to date meaning that the data sets are
ready and available to move away
from the one-size-fits-all treatment
recommendation
which is still more or less the kind of
work that i've been describing
in the lecture today it's essentially
one size fits all
treatment recommendation but it's now
possible to go to a more precise level
at least at the stage of patient groups
meaning what would work for certain
genders certain ages
certain combinations of gender age or
molecular markers
i think then there is another large
group of
very important high impactful questions
in biomedicine to ask
which are related to um
[Music]
temporal aspects of how diseases
progress and how to monitor the uh
patients and help them improve their uh
self-care
so that that's those are important
questions to
to tackle for which data set are
available as well
and then close collaborations with
healthcare systems would offer lots of
opportunities for
kind of um tedious work dds work would
be
optimizing clinical er workflows
identifying medical errors
in um again proposing
systems that have at the end that use
active learning
to then identify um
what when to um
[Music]
when to add another director patient
remove a drug from the patient when to
call the patient to come to
the to the clinic so those are all
exciting questions and some new
questions have emerged during the
pandemic
and type an example of a question that
is new
is that of um
remote medical visits um that is
particularly very
exciting topic nowadays in the interface
of
ai and medical space in particular the
question is
can we design various ai systems that
could
help um doctors
to perform visits remotely in the sense
that
um one would have um
it would be possible to take an image
that of a patient could take
um an image with their app and that
image would be analyzed automatically
um on the patient side and then
communicated to the physician
or and and here in particular active
learning strategy is
is most important to ex for example
identify
what part of the data is most crucial to
have in order to make diagnosis
right and then can that part of the data
be acquired without the patient
necessarily visiting the hospital
and that would be that would enable
um um remote diagnosis and management
uh this is super cool so uh i guess a
follow-up
question um is especially for the first
few
uh problems that you were mentioning why
are graphs essentials like
like why are these graph problems and
you know
not natural language problems or i know
computer vision problems
why do you think graphs are essential in
this case that's a great question i
tried to
shed some light into this question at
the very beginning of the talk
uh a very beginning of this lecture and
um
so the the answer to a question would
have would have would
have be would have two two parts the
first part
is that it's very easy to see
that um most of the problems
in biology are co-dependent or in the
sense of
whatever task we pick up typically
there there are substantial
relationships between important entities
in that test that needs to be modeled
and decades of kind of fundamental
biological research has shown
that those dependencies are really
important and cannot be ignored
so the relational structure of the data
sets is very universal
so we have seen that for essentially all
three problems discussing this talk that
that's indeed the case
and it has been shown over and over
again experimentally from protein
interaction network crispr gene editing
disease diagnosis tasks and so on so so
these are
relations are important component of the
data set so we would need to leverage
models for
use that second is not only that
um these relations exist but
they're in most cases really informative
sometimes even more informative than
than structural data for example for the
problems of predicting uh proteins
uh structure the recent models put out
by deepmind actually
leverage relational uh information about
proteins to infer what their structure
is
um about and and so not only
the data sets and problems are have
strong relational structure
but that relational structure correlates
well with predictive tasks that we want
to
produce and so then some form of graph
based machine learning
seems very suitable
thank you thank you so much one more
question
is about how effective has it been to
get
the medical community to adapt these
methods
um and uh yeah so that i guess is
the question so that's a great question
and the short answer to that is would be
it's it's
challenging so first
to ends to answer that by now we have
seen several
examples of successful deployments of
um these algor ml algorithms in general
in clinical settings as well as in large
pharma companies
so that is primarily true so far for
image based models
um there aren't many or i am not aware
of really successful graph based machine
learning
model that is applied and used routinely
in clinical context or in at least in
public clinical settings
what where where we are currently at
this stage is that
typically individual researchers engage
with collaborators who would be
physicians or clinical researchers and
so on
and they would work hand in hand on
their particular
problems and one could think of that as
validations
experimental validation of predictions
but currently we are not there yet where
these methods would be routinely used
where graph neural networks or graph ml
would be routinely used in
in real world why is that the case so i
would argue that
the main gap that is significant that
exists
between say models published in eurips
papers
and then these models being deployed in
real world
is this lag that typically
when we apply these models to data sets
they don't generate predictions that
users would think of as
actionable predictions what that means
is that
it's not enough to simply predict
whether a drug will treat a disease
it's very hard to convince somebody that
will follow up with very expensive
downstream experiments in the lab
by this high level pointwise based
prediction
so what i didn't discuss in the context
of
repurposing project it was incredibly
important to essentially provide
explanations allowed users to provide
feedback to the model and essentially
build some trust and confidence in the
model and so
that has now given rise to this umbrella
term of trustworthy machine learning
which i think has
has some bearing in the context of
um biomedical applications
uh thank you uh then um two more quick
questions uh
could you elaborate on the node feature
engineering for drug drug interaction
uh the drug combination in the first
part of your talk
and then we have one more yes so
for node features in the first part of
the talk we had node features for drugs
and for proteins
no features for drugs were smiles
fingerprints of drugs
and um they were they were not manually
engineered by by us but this is a very
common descriptor
of drug structure that is used in chemo
informatics it was retreat from
a database called drug bank for
protein nodes the node features were
binary vectors that contain information
about what molecular pathways those
proteins are involved in
for example if we know that a protein a
is uh participates in cell apoptosis
pathway this is a pathway it's
incredibly important because it
basically tells
it it has a control over when a cell
should die
or stay alive right so if a protein is a
member of that pathway
then there would be a simple indicator
one at that
uh in particular in the relevant
dimension of the protein feature vector
all right thank you and then uh one
i'll next question is about uh the g
meta learning how
uh somebody is interested how does it
differ from bayesian network learning
and
em algorithms uh could you discuss pros
and cons
oh i see interesting so we actually
didn't consider anybody's a network
learning method for the problem of
g meta we compared it primarily with um
current work on
um that is graph neural network based
for view shot learning
i i can clearly see from this question
that it might be interesting to use
um some bayesian model and then learn a
distribution of
drug effectiveness across diseases and
then
use that to sample a new disease that
would approximate qubit 19.
um the process of that would be that
using the patient models would perhaps
give us a better ranking of drugs
because ranking of drugs for that
problem was determined on predicted
scores returned by gns and we known uh
and written by gmit in particular from
several applications we know that often
the
scores that are returned by the model
are not necessarily well calibrated or
indicative of probabilities
so i could imagine that the vision
network model might work better for that
so that would be the pros the cause of
that um
would be that um what we found in the
context of
uh covert repurposing is that the g meta
or graph neural network based models
when implemented with
very recent um neighborhood sampling
strategies from like
cluster dc and on graph saint for
example and other
they can scale very well to very large
data sets
including for example one data set where
we looked at
information not only for human but from
from our 1800 other species
and try to translate information from
other species and model organisms like
zebra fish and monkeys to human
and i um at least in my experience in
gene and models scale better to larger
data said than symbol models
thank you so much marinka for the
excellent lecture and
thank you everyone for asking great
questions uh
appreciate it a lot uh thank you so much
and uh
all the best to boston great thank you
for inviting me
yeah thank you bye bye